[Music]
there was some knockdown drag-outs that
I've had with a few people some of it
dealing with the the early drafts of the
script some of it dealing with
eliminating different mechanics from the
game some of it really dealing with your
changing too much of this right you're
going through and you're changing all of
it this isn't God of War anymore and
that argument persisted all the way I
think throughout the development process
it was doubt and fear man those things
were our constant companions throughout
the entirety of the beginning of this
game
[Music]
it was only recently that Cory bar log
became a celebrity in the world of video
games he's been traveling frequently in
the weeks since god of War's release
conducting interviews from sydney to
madrid basking in the game's
overwhelming critical praise but his
relationship with God of War and its
protagonist Kratos dates much farther
back to when he served as lead animator
on the first god of war 13 years ago
Sony Santa Monica then made him director
for both the second and third entries in
the franchise eight months into God of
War 3s development however he left the
team for Crystal Dynamics where he spent
three years reimagining the iconic Tomb
Raider games and in 2013 Santa Monica's
prodigal son returned with a difficult
task ahead of him to not just create a
new god of war but to reinvent the very
identity of the franchise itself we had
just gone through a pretty difficult
time you know like ascension did not get
reviewed well a lot of people were
pretty frustrated with that they put a
lot of time in you know it's not none of
the games we ever worked on our things
to be set up and say yeah we're just
gonna phone it in
nobody ever phones it and they work like
crazy on those things so that shook
people you know when the sci-fi present
got cancelled I inherited people a year
earlier than I expected and I found
myself in a situation where I had to get
a hundred and twenty people excited when
I didn't have a lot I wasn't ready I
wasn't ready I didn't have mechanics
level design worked out the the core
narrative still is in its infancy we
need to give Kratos a fresh start we
need to give the players a fresh start
we need to show him grow we need to
investigate a little bit more about what
it is to be in this world and look at
every decision we make through fresh
eyes the things we were looking at was
really trying to dissect what's
important what's important for the
franchise and then also from that list
what can we actually flip on its head
I think we have to be bold because if we
just release another game that is like
the previous games it's a very small
cross-section of people that are gonna
say that's exactly what I wanted for me
I think you just go back and play those
if you miss those because they're never
going anywhere I'm not gonna go back and
change any of those they're a great part
of our history but the sort of big
change the bold change takes constant
convincing constant years of just trust
me just trust me in previous games we'd
have an inch in and then we'd have core
mechanics and then we would build levels
from those core mechanics while working
out the sort of combat but we sort of
have our levels worked out with our
combat at the same time and this one
everything was getting started and
constructed and theorized at the same
time so across the board we were getting
an engine lighting the ability to build
a level right and a level itself well at
the same time getting all the mechanics
design well the same time figuring out
what the Corps combat loop is literally
everyone is waiting for another person
to finish something because they've got
something else like how can somebody
design a puzzle we don't know what the
puzzle mechanics are all right so we are
basically going over and over again
trying to figure out the solution to the
questions we haven't even figured out
how to ask yet because everybody's at
the same point like I don't ever want to
make a game like that again like that
that was the most that is literally the
most stress you could possibly deal with
it it's like designing a camera and a
film stock while shooting a movie
well then figuring out who you want to
be in it while writing it all in the
same day like everything being decided
and figured out on the same day across
the board it's it is not the way to make
speaking of risks I understand that
having a tray us as like a companion was
a challenge throughout development
that's a challenge is like the the
understatement of the year it was it was
the scariest thing like people were
freaked out about the no cut camera just
cuz the amount of work we had to do and
there are a few unknowns about it but
there's a lot that we could point to as
being okay I think we can figure this
out and there's nobody who's had the
failure story from it companions there's
a lot of failure stories from that right
and that's sometimes worse than having
no information it's just having things
that point to and say look how bad it
was here look how about it was here look
how about it was here and they're saying
if we're gonna take on the Campania
thing we're not going to do what anybody
else has done right the only reference
point I could give them was dead to
rights
I was like it's gonna be like the dog
right except we're gonna go even further
and that he is a a part of the narrative
he is a part of the growth of these
characters but he is also fully
integrated into everything he helps you
with puzzles he is an appendage in
combat so much show that I said think of
it like he's the magic and I feel like
we needed to look at it that he was just
as important to the gameplay loop as he
was to the narrative arc and they get
into that a little bit but then they'd
also realize that's massive and nobody's
really been able to achieve that and how
are we gonna do that and I had no real
answer to that except that we're gonna
go try to learn from everybody else you
know go hang out with people over at
Naughty Dog go talk to everybody that we
can has done any of these companion
these AI characters see what they
learned right what they messed up we
used to send people out constantly over
to gorilla to kind of do the creative
share week where we would exchange
information learn about how their tools
work they learn about how our tools work
and we'd find out wow you guys are doing
it
in a 10 steps - we can do it in one and
then they'd say you're doing it on a
hundred steps and we're doing it in one
so it's fantastic to kind of have that
classic what gdz used to be
developers sharing tricks but even with
that it's not enough it still took
probably tell October of 2017 maybe even
December of 2017 to get tray us working
right so that is scared because that's
that's four years of uncertainty four
years of of you know maybe we should get
rid of the kid and I had many many
conversations that very serious
conversation in the beginning of you
need to cut him right lots of scoping
and it's too big we can't do it I have
my passive-aggressive way of responding
to that which then saved at Reyes in the
game but it didn't end there like the
idea of scoping him down reducing the
impact like trying to figure out maybe
there's a simpler and cheaper way to do
this this isn't so bad right and it was
very very difficult because you know
everybody's on your side like that's the
thing is that I'm notorious perhaps the
for being a conspiracy theorist and I
always think there's an ulterior motive
for everybody and every single thing but
deep down I know that these we're all on
the same team and they're all doing the
best they can and this is their job to
question these things but in the heat of
the moment when this is the fifteenth
conversation you've had about this and
all you need to do is get to the next
meeting and you just need somebody to
trust that this is going to be good it's
hard man
so venturing past the studio's own
borders allowed Santa Monica to adapt to
an ever evolving development scene they
could learn from Sony's other first
party teams choosing to keep their
borders open so as not to suffocate
behind their own walls but Santa Monica
also looked to developers outside of
Sony's portfolio not just current
projects but games that have been around
for decades inspiring a long line of
iterations in their wake we were
influenced by all the games around this
you know we came to the table with our
love of Metroid Castlevania Resident
Evil Onimusha revenue before came out
when we were developing I think - so it
was like the transition between 1 & 2
resi before came out and you know we
follow a lot of the the Japanese game
developers especially in the early years
mostly because we admired all the work
that they had done and there were
several Japanese game developers who
said you know Western universe can't
make a good action game so we were like
we're gonna take you guys on and I think
that love of their games just continued
past that point anyone resin Evil 4 came
out that was as cliched is it that was a
game changer right that was this sense
that they had said the director of NIDA
had said you can't have a controllable
camera and have horror you'll never get
scares it's not possible
and then he totally figured it out and
in a spectacularly amazing way right and
that was inspirational I think everybody
played that game and everybody was
coming into the office and everybody was
talking about it you know interestingly
at the time it didn't inspire us I think
reinvent anything but little did I know
it would inspire later that sense of
bravery and it took seven to come out
that really cemented they're not afraid
to go back and re-examine everything and
that ability to do that and to actually
succeed was a way for me to also inspire
the rest of our team say look at this
second time second time that they've
reinvented their franchise and second
time has totally worked out that they've
done it with passion and sincerity and
earnestness and what comes out of it is
we're not doing this to make a buck
we're not doing this to check a box on
the back of something we're doing this
because we have an idea I had people
coming up to me
maybe a month or two ago having finally
had time to play through the whole game
that said I'm really sorry I doubted
every decision you made or I didn't
believe in half the crap that you were
telling us you know I kept my mouth shut
and really thought you were kind of
ruining this franchise but I just played
through the whole game and I get it now
or the no cut camera was a was a giant
bone of contention and and one of those
things that until you play the whole
game you don't get it fully what we were
trying to do and they come back and say
look I had to I lost a lot of sleep over
this thing
but it was worth it now I get it right
because I see it all together and that's
that's amazing
in talking to bar log the conversation
contained an overwhelming sense of
relief
not just stemming from the fact that God
of War is done or even that it was
well-received but also because the
public was receptive to what at its core
is a very emotional story there's a
moment at the end of the game and they
are spreading the ashes and I had
learned from an earlier thing that I
don't want to talk through it right
maybe too much too many lines too much
talking might ruin the moment listen
this be a silent moment where we pulled
the camera back and it's you know
creatives in a trance standing next to
each other it's just at Reyes willingly
leaning in to dad and dad actually you
know comfortably not awkwardly not not
thinking about it putting his arm around
him and then we'll just kind of let that
moment breathe and there was the right
near the the finally of this because it
was already shot it was already scored
everything was there and we were doing
some ADR and my son had actually said
that he loved me for the first time and
this was unprompted like now
there's a lot of so my son is really
struggling with the language early on
because we're immersing him in Swedish
in English so he is he just parrot and
repeat like it's not a lot that it's
coming directly from him but it was
something that he literally just threw
out there and it absolutely just stopped
me dead in my tracks and I was just like
I didn't want to deal with it I was I
was very overtaken with emotion at that
point and it stuck on me so hard that I
I I think process is subconsciously but
like it's so absolutely personal and
that is throughout like so many moments
that I feel like I'm connecting with
whether it's me and my father
whether honestly it's me and my wife
like there is a lot that we've been
through on this you know I think we all
forget what we put those we love through
to go through these things because I'm
an actual like just an emotional wreck
throughout all these things right
there's so much stress of so many people
applying pressure but then also needing
to kind of be that exposed nerve to be
open to these things to note that is
actually really good why are we not
pushing on that more you know I have a
pretty severe OCD right I'm very
particular about things and I started
noticing early on that I mean he barely
understood language and he had those
same things it broke my heart to see
that I'd pass that on to him and I feel
like this is a it is truly not an
environmental thing it's like a genetic
thing like he he has it worse than I do
to the point where everything in our
lives has to be in a certain order like
you know III cannot open the car door
before he is in a certain place
otherwise he's gonna lose it and there's
a huge part of me that had that and and
I realized like you know what this is
this is something that when you look at
Kratos he looks at God went like a
disease he looks at there's something he
passed on to him and for Kratos he
wanted one thing above all else right it
wasn't vengeance I hope you'll think
okay this is all better no he wanted to
forget he didn't want to have not done
the things that he did he didn't want to
make up for the things
did he wanted somebody to erase it so he
didn't have to carry the memory so the
early edicts that I had with the writers
was saying that you know work years and
we may only succeed in a single moment
of truth in the entire game and if we
succeed in that single moment of truth
we still have a victory right I would
love it if we push ourselves further
beyond that and we have so many moments
of truth throughout all of this game and
all of that is born from being able to
put the mirror on ourselves
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]